翻訳:
校正: Kazunori Akashi
こんにちは 中島聡です
私は本業はソフトウェア
エンジニアですけれども
2004年ぐらいからブログを書いてます
ブログが なんかほとんど
副業のようになっているんですけど
で ブログを書いていて
一番楽しいのは読者の反応ですよね
なんか気の利いたことを書くと
結構コメントをもらえるし
それからFacebook とか Twitter で
色んな人に広まって
たくさんの人に読んでもらえる
それはやっぱりブログを書いていて
一番の楽しみですよね
まぁそうやってかれこれ2,000ぐらいの
ブログのエントリを書いたんですけど
その中でひとつだけ際立って
人気が高い記事があるんですよ
ちょうど６、７年前に
書いた記事なんですけど
いまだにコメントがくるし
最近になって そのネタを元に
本を出したいという話まできて
今日 ちょっと
その話をしたいと思います
簡単にいうと
まぁ私 エンジニアですから
いつもプロジェクトに
関わっているわけですよ
プロジェクトというと
だいたい締切があって
その締切に向けて
どういう態勢で仕事をするかっていう
私のエンジニアとしての
ごく普通の気持ちを書いたものなんですけど
簡単にいうと出来るだけ
はやいうちに形にするんですよ
多くの人がラストスパート型でね
パニックモンスターが
やってきてから頑張るんだけど
僕の場合は本当にある意味
最初にパニックが来るタイプで
ポリシーとして
だいたい最初の２割ぐらいの時間で
８割仕上げないと気が済まないんですよ
で そこから流すんですよ
なぜこういうことを
するようになったかっていうのを
考えてみると ひとつ思い出があって
それは小学校３年生のときに
夏休みの終わりぐらいですよね
私 その頃は理科系少年で
まぁ理科系少年の欠点っていうのは
国語とか社会が大嫌いで
その国語の漢字の書き取りをね
毎日少しずつしなきゃいけなかったものを
もう思いっきりためてたわけですよ
もう夏休み３日ぐらいしかないところで
そんなところに僕の大好きだった
叔父さんが電話をかけてきて
「これから海に行って釣りに行くけど
一緒に行くか」って言われて
「ああ行きます！」って言ったんだけど
当然うちの母親は「だめでしょう」と
「漢字の書き取り
それだけ残っているのに」
で 行かせてくれなかったんですよ
それはもうトラウマのように
僕の心に残って
でね 冗談みたいな話ですけど
小学校４年からは夏休みの宿題は
７月中に終わらせるって決めて
僕やってました
ちょっと日記だけは
難しかったんですけど
（笑）
他のものは本当に
ずっと小学校、中学校って
夏休みの宿題は７月に終わらせるって
だからその後どんな誘いが来ても
行けるっていう風にするって決めて
多分その経験で 今みたいな働き方を
するようになったのかもしれないけど
で 働くようになってからも
ひとつスタートダッシュで働くから
いい思いをしたことがあって
それがマイクロソフトに行った時で
ちょうど私 1989年にシアトルに渡って
シアトルのマイクロソフトの本社で
働くようになったんですよ
その時に配属された部隊が
「次世代OS」—
あんまり専門用語を
使うなって言われてたんですけど
要はパソコンの基本ソフトですよね
それの次世代版を
作るってグループに配属されて
その時 マイクロソフトはIBMと
OS/2 というOSを開発していて
でも僕らのグループはその一歩先
まぁ OS/3 って
呼んでたりしましたけど 中では
それを作るグループだったんですよ
そこに配属されて
僕としてはものすごくはりきってね
初めてアメリカに来て働けるかと思って
頑張って働こうとしたら
実はみんな のんびりしているんですよ
次世代ですから
締め切りないわけですよ
（笑）
で みんなねミーティングはしたり
ドキュメントは書いているんだけど
僕から見ると机上の空論を
しているんですよ
その画面に出てくるアイコンは
いったい何を表すのか？みたいなね
すごく哲学的な理論を延々として
で やっぱりその「もの」がないから
何も決まらないんですよ
その状況は僕は耐えられなくて
で 上司にかけあって
「僕は手を動かさないと
考えられないタイプなんで」
今もそうですけど
「だから何か作らせてくれ」って言ったら
「じゃあ君そのプロトタイプを
作りなよ」と
そのOSの議論はしているけど
やっぱり目に見えるカタチがあった方が
いいからということで
プロトタイプを１人で３ヶ月くらいで
作らせてもらいましたけど
それはもうほんっとに楽しかったですよ
今までの長いエンジニア人生の中でも
最も楽しかった時期のひとつかな
ていうのも そのマイクロソフトっていう
でっかい会社が
次世代のOSを開発するときの
プロトタイプですけど
どんなカタチになったらいいよ —
将来のパソコンは
どう動くべきかっていうのを
僕ひとりが運転席に座って
全部図面を描いて
全部作るっていうチャンスを
与えられたわけですよ
もう それは嬉しくて
本当に毎日夜遅くまで働いて
土日も出て
24時間そのこと考えてましたよ
そんな僕を見て
みんなが不思議がるわけですよ
せっかくこんなのんびりした
次世代OSを作るっていうチームにいるのに
お前なんで こんな一所懸命
働いているんだ？って
僕にとっては楽しくてしょうがないから
そういう時にモチベーションが
ものすごくあがるタイプなんですよ
で そうやっているうちに
段々みんな分かってきてくれてね
っていうのは その
今まで机上の空論だったものが
手にとってさわっていじってと
できることになると
だいぶ色んなことが
見えてくるわけですよ
あ こうやった方が使い難い
使いやすいなとか
この方が分かりやすいなとか
で そうこうしているうちに僕の上司が
マイクロソフトの
ひとり えらい人を連れてきて —
副社長だったんですけど —
デモを見せてほしいって言うので
見せたところ
「これはなかなか面白いな」と
「今度 是非プレゼンして欲しい」って
頼まれたんですよ
それは嬉しかったですよ
僕もまだぺーぺーのエンジニアで
日本からアメリカに来たばっかりで
プレゼンするなんて
大チャンスじゃないですか
だからもう すごい頑張ったんですけど
あんまりその時は
英語がしゃべれなかったんで
僕がしゃべらなくてもデモ自身がその
僕の考えていることを全部
表現するようにしようということで
またその後すっごく夜遅くまで働いて
そのデモを完璧なものに
していったわけですよ
そのデモさえ見れば
僕が思う「将来のパソコンは
こう動くべきだ」みたいな
アイデアが全部含まれていて
で その中にちゃんと
ジョークも入れたんですよ
僕の上司がイタリア人で
ひげもじゃだったんですけど
そのユーザ登録の時に
わざわざ顔アイコンを選べるようにして
そこにひげもじゃなイタリア人が
出てくるみたいなシナリオまで入れて
完璧に準備して行ったんですよ
で プレゼン会場に行って
ひとつ驚いたんですよ
っていうのは僕は頭っから
社内向けのプレゼンだと思っていたら
実はそれはマイクロソフトが年に１度だけ
パソコンメーカーとか
ソフトウェアベンダー向けにやる
大きなイベントで
２千人ぐらい お客さんいるんです
（笑）
後から聞いたら最前列には
IBM、Compaq、Intel の社長クラスが
いるっていう すごいプレゼンで
なぜか そのコンファレンスで
プレゼンすることになってしまって
その上 司会の人が
僕の発表の前に
「マイクロソフトは今 IBMと
OS/2というOSを開発してますけど
実は将来のことも考えています
今回その将来のOS 本邦初公開です！」
みたいなことでアナウンスされちゃって
もうなんか典型的なね —
まぁ後から聞いたんですけど
これはベーパーウェアと呼ぶ
要はマイクロソフトの
誇大広告のひとつなんですけど
それにもうのせられてしまって
で プレゼンすることになったんですけど
まぁしょうがないですよね
幸いなことにデモは
完璧なものを用意していたんで
デモをしたら 笑いを取るところでは
ちゃんと笑いを取れたし
終わった時には満場の拍手でしたよ
その話は結構 色んな人から
後から言われましたよ
Compaq のえらい人から
「君のプレゼンは良かったよ」みたいなこと
それは僕にとっては
すごい良い成功体験でしたね
会社 特にマイクロソフトや
ものを作る会社において
みんながのんびりしている時に
思いきり働くことの有意義さとか
それからなるたけ早いうちに
目に見えるカタチ さわれるカタチに
することの重要さみたいなことは
すごく学びましたよね
その後もその方法を使って
ずっと働くようにしました
結果から言うと その時つくった
プロトタイプがベースになって
Windows95 っていうのが出来たし
僕自身も Windows95 の開発に
深くかかわることが出来たのは
やっぱりそういうことを
したためかなと思います
ちなみにスライドがなかったので
ひとつ ふたつだけ
今日はスライドがあります
作ってきたのは左側が
ラストスパート型で働く人の働き方ですね
横軸が時間で 縦軸が完成度
最初はのんびりとやっていて
途中で締め切りが迫ってきて
パニックモンスターが
やって来ると頑張るっていう
わたしのやり方は
ロケットスタートとか呼びますけど
最初の２割の時間で
８割仕上げるようになっているんです
で その後は流す
それがわたしの働き方です
そうは言っても
結局この話を色んな人にしても
みんな理解してくれないし
できないんです
本当に８割方の人が
ラストスパート型で働きますよね
なぜそうなるのかというのを
考えてきたんですけど
ひとつは学校の勉強が
あるんじゃないかと思うんですよ
学校っていうのは
一学期のある決まった期間に
あるものを勉強しなきゃいけなくて
で その最後に
試験とかレポートを書いてる
で それを勉強したことを
証明するのですから
その環境におけると実はラストスパート型で
なんとかなっちゃうんです
もしくはラストスパート型の方が
効率が良かったりするし
あと学校っていうその社会の中では
みんなが遊んでいる時に勉強すると
変な奴じゃないですか
そうすると みんなが
遊んでいるときは一緒に遊んで
試験前になると勉強をするっていう方が
社会的に効率がいいということもあって
結局みんなで引き摺られて
試験前だけ勉強するっていうことを
高校、大学と繰り返すわけですよ
それが何か勉強のリズムとして
身についてしまって
社会人になっても
同じことをするんじゃないかなと
わたしは思っている
社会に出たときのプロジェクトと
学校の勉強とは全然違うんですよ
やられた方は分かると思うんですけど
３ヶ月でこのプロジェクトは
できそうだなって始めてみたら
実は６ヶ月かかる１年かかるってことが
しばしばあるんですよ
もしくはソフトウェアの場合だと
こういう設計で作ろうって言って
作ってみて８割方できてみたら
性能がでないなと
で 何が悪いかっていうと
あぁ設計が悪いんじゃないかと
じゃ一回ゼロから作り直しだな
みたいなことは しばしばあるんです
想定外の状況って呼んでもいいけど
そういう状況に
ラストスパート型は弱いんです
なぜ弱いかって言うと
色んなことが見えてくる —
例えば使い勝手がいいのかとか
本当に性能がでるのかっていうのは
やっぱり８割方作ったところなので
その８割方作ったって言うのが
どの時点で見えるかっていうのが
矢印で示してあるんですけど
このラストスパート型だと
本当に締め切りギリギリに
８割出来るわけです
その時点で使い勝手悪かったから
直そうって言っても
時間ないじゃないですか
だから延びちゃうんですよ
間に合わないんですよ
特に最悪なのが
例えば「性能が出ない」
その原因が設計にある時なんかです
本当だったらね
設計が悪いんだから
ゼロから作り直さなきゃ
ならないんですけど
もうこの時点になったら
そんなことしてられないですよね
わたしよく見てますけど
そういう状況に陥ったエンジニアが
何をするかって言うと
設計が悪かったっていうことを
認めないんですよ
本人は心の中で知っているんだけど
今さらそんなこと言えないじゃないですか
締め切りまでもう３日しかないのに
「設計間違ってました
ゼロから作り直すしかありません」
とは言えないので
結局 対症療法だけで
しのごうとするんですよ
それをすると何がおこるかと言うと
結局 根本設計が悪いから
パフォーマンスが出ない
バグだらけになる 使い勝手悪い
どうしようもないことに
陥っていくんですよ
だからいつまでたっても 徹夜しようが
残業しようが 週末働こうが
いつまでたっても
終わらないっていう状況に陥る
ソフトウェア業界では
「デスマーチ」って呼んでるんですけど
その一番の原因は 実は設計にあり
なぜその設計が悪いことが
ここまで分からなかったかというと
ラストスパート型だからですよ
これをスタートダッシュ型で作ると
だいたい最初の２割の時間で ８割作る
そこで見えてくるわけです
そこで例えば使い勝手が
悪かったなって言ったら
直す時間は十分あるし
万が一 その設計が
根本的に悪かったって
この時点だったら一回ゼロから
作りなおすこともできるわけですよ
そういう意味で圧倒的に
このスタートダッシュ型のほうが
有利なんですよ
で 今日はこの話をして
基本的には このメッセージなんですけど
こういう話を聞いてもね
なんか「いい話だなー」って言って
そのままこう…
（笑）
結局「自分には関係ない」とか
「できない」とか言う人が
多いと思うんだけど
実はこうやって
見てもらうと分かるように
働いている量は 実際
変わらないじゃないですか トータルの
いつ頑張るかの違いでしかないんですよ
だから できるできないの話じゃなくて
やるかやらないかの話なんですよ
例えばマラソンランナーで
一流の人たちっていうのは
ペース配分を知ってるじゃないですか
それと同じように
こういうプロジェクトに関わる —
別にエンジニアじゃなくて
デザイナだったり
企画の人でもいいんだけど
こういうプロジェクトに
仕事として関わるんであれば
やっぱりペース配分ぐらいは
ちゃんとやりましょうよと そういう話です
ありがとうございます
（拍手）